[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue une fois n'est pas coutume nous
consacrerons l'intégralité de notre
émission à un seul sujet l'intervention
importante du président de la république
c'était en fin de matinée sur ce que le
chef de l'état appelle le séparatisme
islamistes pour parler de ce sujet deux
invités la libérale l'autre un peu moins
je vous laisse deviner qui est qui bon
choix revient à diaries vous êtes
analyste en politiques publiques à
l'iref j'aide un peu nos internautes en
rappelant que c'est un think tank de
sensibilité libérale et vous êtes
délégué général de l'académie des
sciences humaines et puis guillaume
bernard est là avec nous bonsoir sodium
vous êtes maître de conférences à
l'institut catholique d'études
supérieures à la roche-sur-yon et vous
êtes l'auteur chacun d'eux c'est de la
guerre à droite aura bien lieu le
mouvement dextrogyre c'est publié aux
éditions déclics bruère il y avait
beaucoup de thèmes au menu du discours
du président de la république c'était en
fin de matinée en région parisienne aux
mureaux le chef de l'état voulait mettre
le cadre général de ce qui sera un
projet de loi présenté ultérieurement au
conseil des ministres
le thème c'est donc la lutte contre le
séparatisme islamiste est l'un des axes
du président de la république était de
s'assurer que l'école soit bien celle de
la république pour tous les français et
il a notamment annoncé que désormais
l'école et main ça se passerait à
l'école écoutez
dès la rentrée 2021 l'instruction à
l'école sera rendue obligatoire pour
tous dès 3 ans l'instruction à domicile
sera strictement limitée notamment aux
impératifs de santé
nous changeons donc de paradigme et
c'est une nécessité qui ont bernard le
chef de l'état a aussi annoncé une
surveillance accrue de ce que l'on
appelle les écoles hors contrat est ce
que ça vous paraît un bonne axe pour
lutter contre l'islamisme
non et bien non je suis outré par les
mesures qui sont annoncées par le
président de la république sous prétexte
que l'état n'est pas capable de
contrôler l'islamisme eh bien ils
utilisent
l'interdiction est il détruit les
libertés de tous et en particulier des
libertés je vais pas faire de la
philosophie du droit mais des libertés
naturel des libertés de droit naturel
des parents de choisir le mode
d'instruction de leurs enfants
l'interdiction de l'instruction a
à domicile le fait d'obliger des enfants
dès 3 ans qui ont peut-être autre chose
à faire et qui peuvent être parfaitement
éveillé dans le cadre de leurs familles
de les obliger d'aller à l'école je
trouve que c'est une mesure liberticide
et je suis effectivement scandalisée par
le fait que l'état est bien n'étant pas
capable et bien de juguler un phénomène
social et idéologique l islamisme et
bien il détruit les libertés de tous
donc vraiment je suis fais partie de
ceux je crois que je ne suis pas le seul
parce que petit à petit ça va quand même
passer dans l'opinion que ce sont des
mesures scandaleuses évidemment et c'est
ça qui va être utilisé on va te dire
donc ça voudrait dire que vous ne voulez
pas lutter contre l'islamisme c'est du
chantage
scandaleux il ya bien d'autres moyens de
lutter contre l'islamisme que détruire
les libertés de tous ceux qui non
seulement ne sont pas musulmans ils sont
encore moins islamiste mais vous ne
pensez pas qu'on peut parfois accepter
un moindre mal pour éviter un mal plus
grands je crois que le bien commun c'est
la combinaison et du bien des parties du
bien du tout c'est à dire que si on
détruit la liberté des femmes ici on
détruit la liberté d des enfants et bien
on ne réalise pas ou ne réalise pas le
bien commun on réalise peut-être une
partie de l'intérêt de l'intérêt général
mais sûrement pas le bien commun non
alors comme ça vous en direct je ne peux
pas refaire le lancement de l'émission
sinon je recommencerai parce que
finalement il ya peut-être deux libéraux
autour de cette table je vais faire la
subsidiarité je déforme le droit naturel
au sens je dirais de droits attribués à
la personne n'est pas le libéralisme en
tant que doctrine subjectiviste je crois
que c'est inutile de lancer une
polémique maintenant ferghana diaries
est ce que vous partagez la vidéo que je
partage en grande partie ce qui vient
d'être dit en effet c'est à dire que
c'est comme si finalement sous prétexte
il y avait deux ou trois journaux qui
diffuse une idéologie totalitaire il
fallait contrôler la presse en tant que
tel et amélie la liberté de la presse en
raison des errements de quelques-uns
donc je pense qu'on était que la mesure
ici elle est disproportionnée toutefois
l'objectif on est d'accord par tout le
monde sera d'accord
ici autour de ce plateau pour dire qu'il
faille lutter contre l'islam radical
voire l'islam tout court si on considère
comme moi que cette religion est
intrinsèquement autoritaire là où on va
différer c'est sur les moyens d'y
parvenir et je pense qu'il ya en effet
deux moyens d'y parvenir il ya un moyen
politique
et puis il ya un moyen on va dire plus
décentralisée qui consiste à recourir à
la société civile c'est à dire aux
intellectuels aux médias à considérer
finalement que la lutte contre l'islam
radical est un combat culturel
avant d'être un combat politique et moi
je suis en effet de ceux qui pensent que
c'est un combat culturel et non pas
étatiques et je ne suis pas de ceux qui
pensent qu'une idéologie totalitaire une
religion totalitaire soit comment dire
soit impossible à défaire en tout cas
sur le plan culturel il ya un parallèle
que j'aime bien faire en ce qui me
concerne c'est le cas du communisme par
exemple quand planait il y à quelques
décennies la menace du totalitarisme
communiste et pas qu'un peu puisque vous
vous souvenez peut-être qu'à l'époque et
avec des intellectuels qui avait pignon
sur rue qui faisait l'apologie de l'urss
dans les médias balle en jeu pour des
gens comme raymond aron jean françois
revel ou autre figure de la lutte contre
le totalitarisme
eh bien c'était de déconstruire
l'idéologie communiste en tant que telle
n'est pas de mendier auprès de l'état
des interdictions des lois ne pas
mandaté finalement des magistrats et les
fonctionnaires pour sonder le coeur des
gens ce qui consiste à considérer à
avaliser quelque part une partie du
paradigme totalitaire donc mais si c'est
le même combat c'est à dire que je pense
que le combat contre l'islam radical est
avant tout un combat culturel et que
l'état lui et bien on doit se contenter
d'arbitré et de garantir l'ordre public
mais c'est un combat qui appartient la
société civile à mon avis et non pas à
l'état en tant que monopole de la
violence légale alors nos internautes ne
sont pas forcément d'accord avec vous et
même assez même assez largement le
contraire enfin voici en tout cas des
avis divergents celui de billy sur
twitter qui nous dit quand tu à l'école
à la maison et
apprend l'arabe en lisant le coran c'est
un problème alors que l'école en france
est une des fondations des valeurs de la
république
alors selon moi oui cette loi est une
bonne idée sachant toujours sur sa
chance cette fois sur youtube
renchérit apprendre à nos enfants à bien
vivre ensemble ça commence par les
laisser à prendre ensemble tout petit
quelle que soit l'origine et la religion
est en revanche à mettre sur youtube
nous dit du n'importe quoi cette lutte
contre l'islam la france est tout sauf
un pays de liberté de culte donc ça
c'est une réflexion un peu plus générale
sur le discours présidentiel
cela étant même si je viens de vous lire
des commentaires d'internautes qui sont
plutôt en désaccord avec vous messieurs
quand nous posons la question à nos
internautes sur twitter pensez vous que
l'école rendu obligatoire dès l'âge de 3
ans peut être efficace dans la lutte
contre le séparatisme islamistes la
réponse c'est quand même nom à 61%
il ya aussi cette question de christophe
sur lefigaro.fr qu'en est il des femmes
voilées lors des sorties scolaires
macron en at il parlé emmanuel macron on
ne souhaite pas changer la règle c'est à
dire obliger les accompagnatrices de
sorties scolaires à enlever leur voile
vous savez qu'il y avait un débat sur ce
sujet puisque l'idée était que quand on
accompagne sorties scolaires on
participe au service public donc on est
contraint à une forme de neutralité ce
qui semble-t-il n'est pas le point de
vue du du président de la république
guillaume bernard est ce que il ya
d'autres choses qui vous ont choqué et
qui vous semblent contraires aux
principes que vous annonciez en début
d'émission dans les annonces du
président macron tout simplement la
contradiction même des mesures qu'il
prend pas ce que je voudrais pas
polémiquer avec certains internautes
mais quand ils nous disent à l'école on
va apprendre le vivre ensemble
bon je suis pas sûr qu'ils apprennent
grand chose à l'école et pas même le
vivre ensemble mais justement d'un côté
quand même y arriver les programmes
d'élèves de l'école maternelle
oui oui peut-être qu'il faudrait les
revoir ses programmes et peut-être
vaudrait-il mieux laisser aux écoles et
aux enseignants la faculté de
décidé justement de ces programmes et on
verra bien quelle sont les écoles qui
attireront vraiment des parents et des
enfants plutôt que d'imposer quelque
chose d'uniformiser mais justement ce
qui me paris scandaleuse ce qui me
paraît c'est la subsidiarité la
subsidiarité peut se rejoindre le
libéralisme sur certains points pour
autant le catholicisme social ne rejoint
pas le libéralisme sur d'autres points
bon mais en tout cas en tout cas en tout
cas d'un côté on a donc macron qui nous
explique que il prend des mesures
liberticides
parce que l'état n'est pas capable de
juguler le phénomène social et
idéologique de l'islamisme et de l'autre
côté il va dépenser de l'argent pour des
études islamistes il va donc l'argent du
contribuable ça va faire plaisir à notre
avis fergane il va imposer ou favoriser
le développement de l'arabe ce sont deux
mesures totalement et pour acheter la
paix sociale
donc d'un côté il tue les libertés ou
disons il est restreint et de l'autre
côté il veut essayer d'acheter la paix
sociale
ce qui n'a évidemment jamais fonctionné
donc là on est dans une situation
ubuesque où sous prétexte qu'on ne peut
pas empêcher ou véritablement contrôler
l'islamisme il va favoriser le
développement de l'islam tout court
et donc ils vont l'islam et l'islamisme
vont y être gagnants sur tous les
terrains sur tous les tableaux
parce que évidemment les islamistes vont
se déclarer martyrs et donc ils vont se
développer de manière souterraine tandis
que officiellement et par le fait que
l'état va intronisé reconnaître la
légitimité d'un certain nombre
d'institutions et bien l'état va
favoriser le développement de l'islam
tout court
donc qu'ils soient hard ou qu'ils soient
soft le djihad a de beaux jours devant
lui grâce à la puissance publique
alors vous parliez de l'enseignement
de l'arabe il s'agit de ce qu'on appelle
le iiiè le enseignement optionnel des
langues vivantes étrangères qui en fait
sont des cours qui sont dispensés sur la
base du volontariat mais dans les
établissements publics par des
enseignants qui pour les enseignants de
langue arabe deviennent assez largement
de pays étrangers comme la turquie ou
des pays de l'afrique du nord
et ça car dès lors de l'ago risée
l'assimilation ferghana diaries est ce
que vous partagez ce jugement on va dire
globalement négatif de guillaume bernard
sur les sur le le projet présidentiel
il a un petit peu sévère mais il ya
aussi un peu de vrai dans ce qui est des
sur la halle des atteintes portées à la
liberté de l'enseignement encore une
fois c'est vrai que là on fait payer
on induit une restriction générale pour
un problème particulier mais ça vous
démontrer par instants mais qu'il y ait
des petits enfants de 2 3 ans qui
apprennent à lire dans le coran qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient instruites par des
imams radicaux on sait à quel point on
peut être influençable à cet âge là
c'est c'est quand même un blanc vous
allez faire disparaître les islams
radicaux parce que vous allez mettre des
enfants de 3 ans de manière générale
quelle que soit en france partout en
france à l'école de manière obligatoire
je ne sais pas j'ai accéléré les islams
les lélés comment dire les islamistes
radicaux
on les expulse on les déchoir de leur
nationalité
on les emprisonne lorsqu'ils commettent
des infractions mais on ne porte pas
atteinte à la liberté des parents de
choisir quand ils font inscrire leurs
enfants et où ils le froid s'ouvrir très
clair là dessus je souscris en effet je
pense que le problème encore une fois
est le même que celui la presse et pas
parce que vous avez des journaux qui
peuvent influencer une opinion publique
jules né râble en propageant des
idéologies autoritaire qu'il faille s'en
prendre à la liberté de la presse
l'école pour moi c'est exactement le
même dilemme c'est le même souci
maintenant là où je pense qu'on a un
problème c'est que non seulement on n'a
pas compris que la lutte contre l'islam
radical voire la lutte contre l'islam
tout court et est un problème culturel
qui appartenait à la société civile en
tant que tel mais on n'a pas non plus
identifié les barrières qui font
qu'aujourd'hui cette société civile elle
peine à se réapproprier cette question
elle même et là je pense qu'une espèce
de paradoxe parce qu'il ya la fois un
excès de zèle du côté de l'état et en
même temps un laxisme du côté de la
société civile
pourquoi parce que nous sommes encore
victimes aujourd'hui de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler dans le débat public un
syndrome post coloniale c'est à dire que
la colonisation ayant jadis étaient
justifiées sur l'idée juste que toutes
les cultures ne se valent pas eh bien on
en a déduit l'erreur qu'il fallait
finalement imposé cette vérité par la
force du glaive et la conclusion a fini
par soulever la prémisse est aujourd'hui
on suspecte l'universalisme d'être le
paravent de l'impérialisme est donc ce
complexe la fête que nous avons
aujourd'hui du mal en tant qu'individu
en tant que commentateur en tant qu est
saisissant tant qu'intellectuel a
critiqué cette religion pour ce qu'elle
est parce que on
on est effrayé par le fait d'être taxé
ensuite de raciste ou d' impérialistes
donc le complexe post coloniale est en
réalité le premier obstacle à lever pour
rendre pour des pour vous rendre la
critique de l'islam moins tabou qu'elle
ne l'est aujourd'hui
mais c'est encore une fois quelque chose
qui appartient à la société civile
je ne crois pas qu'il faille en faire
une affaire d'état ma part des réactions
d'internautes 1 sur ce sujet particulier
de l'enseignement possible de l'arabe à
l'école avant l'arabe
il faut lui apprendre le français
correctement considère gertrude sur
lefigaro.fr et puis au minium toujours
sur lefigaro.fr l'arabe à l'école n'est
ce pas favorisé a contrario la sécession
le séparatisme point d'interrogation
je vous propose si c'est possible qu'on
écoute maintenant d'avoir le point de
vue de jean marie des doigts quel
rédacteur en chef en charge des
questions religieuses au figaro et qui
lui aussi effectivement ou lui aussi
comme vous plus exactement parce
qu'effectivement ça chaque internaute
d'en juger considère que c'est l'un des
points faibles du dispositif
présidentiel branche choix que la grande
faiblesse de discours et menville erreur
magistrats c'est l'enseignement de la
langue arabe parce que pourquoi est-ce
qu'on tient à ce que les enfants
musulmans apprennent l'arabe pour
mémoriser le coran s'ils ne possèdent
pas l'arabe ne peuvent pas mémorisé le
coran est là le présent pour un risque
majeur c'est à dire il confirme
finalement l'inscription de la culture
de l'islam en france à travers la langue
alors que il aurait pu dire nous allons
renforcer l'enseignement du français
guillaume bernard salomé sur youtube
vous pose la question de façon assez
directe mais quelles solutions
proposez-vous monsieur bernard vous avez
déjà dit l'expulsion dé des imams
radicaux
oui l'expulsion des imams radicaux est
tout simplement une vraie politique
d'assimilation
c'est à dire pour ceux qui ne veulent
pas l'assimilation et bien c'est le
départ et pour ceux qui veulent bien
l'assimilation ça veut dire une
véritable conversion à la france une
conversion culturel pourquoi pas
religieuse mais aussi culturelles et je
crois qu'il ne faut pas se cacher
derrière son petit doigt la france là le
régime actuel la république
et peut-être dit laïc il n'empêche que
le corps social qu'est la france a une
identité à une histoire et même plus
qu'une histoire parce qu'on pourrait
toujours me dire oui mais la sociologie
évolué la composition du peuple évolué
la france a une ontologie est par
exemple on vous parlait de lui eh bien
ça veut dire qu'il faut connaître et
aimer et apprécier pas simplement
connaître intellectuellement mais
apprécié ce qu'est l'identité de la
france
donc oui la réponse à l'islamisme c'est
c'est l'assimilation culturelle et ça
n'est pas autre chose et je cours je
rejoins alors je le formule de manière
un peu différente peut-être de manière
un peu plus musclée que fergane mais oui
bien entendu
c'est un problème de comment dire de
d'identité de vie du corps social est
pas un problème de la puissance de la
puissance publique
alors si vous le voulez bien continuons
à découvrir ensemble les différentes
propositions du président de la
république il ya un autre thème qu'il a
employés ce qui peut être une belle
expression c'est celle d' islam des
lumières et voilà ce qu'en dit le chef
de l'état
de bâtir
sion qui va nous permettre je l'espère
je le crois de construire un islam des
lumières dans notre pays c'est à dire un
islam qui puisse être en paix avec la
république en respectant toutes les
règles de séparation et en permettant
d'apaiser toutes les voix ce n'est pas
le travail de l'état de structurer les
hommes mais nous devons nous permettre
d'accompagner cette émergence et nous
allons essayer de répondre à cette
question posée par mehdi sur youtube
sommes nous en train d'inventer un islam
français et j'en profite pour remercier
les internautes très nombreux qui
débattent avec nous en direct à la fois
sur le figaro.fr sur youtube et sur
twitter même si je ne peux pas citer
toutes les réactions
elles nourrissent le débat comme vous
pouvez en juger alors parmi les moyens
que souhaite mettre en oeuvre le
président de la république pour faire
émerger un islam qui puisse être en paix
avec la répub avec la république
décidément elle est partout l'idée de
former de certifier des imart alors ce
serait pas l'état qui s'occuperait de ça
mais le conseil français du culte
musulman le cfcm à qui l'état
déléguerait 7 cette mission ferghana
dire est ce que ça vous paraît une bonne
idée c'est à dire que on sait que
l'islam contrairement à d'autres
religions comme le catholicisme n'est
pas organisé et en fait on peut devenir
un imam sans forcément avoir une
formation particulière l'idée d'encadrer
tout ça est ce que ça vous paraît
bienvenus déjà ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que je suis très sceptique sur l'
usage du terme islam des lumières
parce que je crois que c'est ici un
espèce d'acte de foi dans la toute
puissance de l'exégèse et je ne suis pas
convaincu aujourd'hui que toutes les
religions que toutes les idéologies soit
plastique soit également soluble dans la
modernité occidentale dans la liberté
dans l'égalité c'est quelque chose qu'on
admet d'ailleurs pour plein d'idéologie
politique quand par exemple on parle du
communisme pour revenir à ce
totalitarisme là parce que j'aime bien
faire ce parallèle bas quand les
et les intellectuels qui à l'époque
lutte contre le totalitarisme le
combattent le communisme il n'essayait
pas de l'interpréter à la lumière de la
civilisation occidentale et du
libéralisme des sociétés ouvert parce
qu'ils savent bien que c'est impossible
c'est cette idéologie étant
intrinsèquement autorité hadopi
l'exégèse n'a pas tous les pouvoirs
c'est la raison pour laquelle par
exemple aucun exégètes n'atteint
toujours prétendu être suffisamment
talentueux pour interpréter mein kampf à
la lumière du philosémitisme et je
crains qu'aujourd'hui nous oublions que
les religions ont parfois une essence un
noyau dur
au delà du teil l'interprétation vos
dénaturation est donc cet islam des
lumières moi me semble une espèce
d'illusion pour ne pas avoir à poser la
question peut être douloureuse de la
bienveillance de cette religion en tant
que telle comme si finalement nous
redoutions d'inviter les musulmans à
prendre une distance critique avec leur
religion a essayé de les séduire et
essayer de convertir à d'autres
croyances peut-être plus bienfaitrice et
a essayé de les aider à réaliser que
cette religion en tant que telle
finalement n'a pas grand chose à offrir
à l'humanité qui vaudrait mieux la
laisser de côté plus qui essaye de la
faire entrer dans un moule républicain
occidental ce qui moi me paraît être une
peine perdue
oui mais il ya il ya des intellectuels
musulmans qui essayent de de bonne foi
et façon certainement parfaitement
sincère de retrouver ce chemin de
trouver cette voie ils me disent alors
le car en son nom m'échappe à l'instant
de cet intellectuel musulman qui avait
notamment traduit en français le coran
et qui était je crois à l'origine de
cette expression du sable des lumières
même s'il reconnaissait qu'il est voilà
c'était malek chebel même s'il
reconnaissait pour le regretter qu'il se
sentait plutôt minoritaire
oui tout comme il ya eu des marxistes
qui ont de bonne foi essayer de
concilier le marxisme avec la liberté
tous qu'il ya peut-être de bonne foi des
gens qui pensent que le nationalisme
autoritaire et solide en la liberté donc
on peut toujours essayer de faire entrer
une idéologie dans un moule libéral mais
je pense que c'est oublier que toutes
les idéologies encore une fois ne sont
pas également soluble savez s'agissant
du socialisme là encore jean françois
revel avec cette formule assez parlante
quand on lui opposait la possibilité
d'interpréter le socialisme a trait à la
lumière du
réalisme dès maintenant le socialisme et
démocratique dans la proportion même où
il est moins socialiste mais moi j'ai
l'impression que pour l'islam c'est un
peu la même chose c'est à dire que
l'islam est entre guillemets libéral et
démocratique dans la proportion même où
il est moins islamique
et tant qu'on n'aura pas réalisé cela je
pense qu'on sera empêtré dans des
contradictions insolubles
guillaume herbach est ce que vous pensez
de cette idée de pouvoir former et
certifier des imams dont l'enseignement
et les principes soient soient
compatibles avec les valeurs qui sont
les nôtres
ça me paraît parfaitement utopique alors
évidemment on a l'exemple du concordat
de 1801 qui continuent à s'appliquer en
alsace-moselle je suppose qu évidemment
certains voudraient se servir de ce
modèle là pour peut-être de manière
édulcorée sans que ce soit l'état
directement qui interviennent et bien
favorisé je dirais eu une surveillance
et une canalisation par l'état de la
religion
on sème la peur est l'exemple de
napoléon avec la religion juive oui oui
oui je n'en suis pas je n'en suis pas
persuadé pour une raison simple qui est
que il y a une conception intrinsèque je
dirais à l'islam
il n'y a pas besoin d'être islamistes
cela qui est de concevoir la politique
l'ordre politique au service d'une
finalité religieuse la distinction des
domaines du christianisme qui est au
fondement de notre société et qui est
tout de même assez différent mais là ça
nous emmènerait trop loin la séparation
de l'église et de l'état
mais enfin la distinction du spirituel
et du temporel qui sont tous les deux
donc dans l'ordre public
et bien c'est quelque chose qui est
totalement étranger totalement étranger
à l'islam donc je crois que ça n'est pas
une que ça n'est pas une bonne idée que
c'est utopique que dans le fond macron a
essayé de faire aujourd'hui aux mureaux
l'équivalent du discours des bernardins
qui l'avait fait devant l'église
catholique en disant voilà nous avons
nous et a le monopole de l'espace public
nous avons nous puissance politique le
monopole sur l'espace public mais nous
allons vous permettre comme elle de vous
exprimer à condition que vous acceptiez
un indifférente isme c'est à dire le
fait que toutes les religions soient
mises sur un pied d'égalité et qu'elle
soit comment dire dans le fond
considéré comme participant à la vie
sociale mais mais mais mais pas plus ça
veut donc dire que dans le fond l'état
est prêt à essayer pour ce qui concerne
je dirais le l'islam a dont le fond
essayer de le structurer
qu'est ce qui fait aujourd'hui la
faiblesse de l'islam et de l'islamisme
au niveau international et y compris en
france
et bien c'est le fait qu'ils sont
divisés c'est le fait que c'est diviser
d'un point de vue je dirais d'un certain
nombre je dirais de chapelle de dogme un
les chiites les sunnites et c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas en tout cas pour le l'islam
sunnite de structuration ils n'ont pas
d'église et l'état est en train de leur
offrir sur un plateau la possibilité de
se structurer et donc de devenir
véritablement une organisation
susceptible de conques de concurrencer
l'état je crois ça je crois que c'est
que c'est de la folie quant à la comptal
à comment dire quant à la question
idéologique
macron semble croire dans le fond que il
y aurait la possibilité d'imposer à
l'islam ce que l'état a il ya quelques
dessinée déjà réussi malheureusement à
mon goût a imposé à l'église catholique
c'est c'est je crois oui c'est utopique
dans le fond il se voit en réalisateur
de western
1 le bon la brute et le mécréant mais
alors y aurait le bon le bon le le bon
le bon musulman la brute islamique et
est évidemment la victime le mécréant et
est donc sous prétexte qu'il y aurait un
bon et une brute et bien il faudrait
favoriser le bon et lui permettre de se
développer
moi je ne le je ne crois pas que ce soit
quelque chose de que ce soit quelque
chose devrait amender vous il n'ya pas
de différence là je rejoins et j'ai
promis je termine et il ya ce long
tunnel
il n'y a pas à mon sens de véritable
différence de nature entre l'islam et
l'islamisme ya simplement une différence
de degré écoeuré laure délie nam est
fort et bien il est islamique que
répondez-vous à deng qui nous dit sur
lefigaro.fr toutes les religions n'ont
pas de plasticité s'être ce probablement
aucune religion la plasticité pour les
catholiques il a fallu des siècles avant
que la religion de sa souplesse est vrai
par exemple il a fallu du temps avant
que les catholiques reconnaissent la
république
tous ne le font pas nécessairement vous
appartient effectivement au moins si on
reconnaît là la cohérence de votre de
votre raisonnement et de votre de votre
devoir 6 et sortir ses goûts et de mon
corps mais enfin que mais pas du tout
trouvé cette semaine un sujet sur lequel
avec avec lequel je ne suis pas d'accord
avec eric zemmour on entasse assure
enfin trouvé ça c'est un autre c'est un
autre
sujet au minium sur lefigaro.fr nous
disent il y avait un islam français cet
islam aurait un texte en français et non
en arabe j'imagine que c'est une
allusion au coran même si celui ci est
et traduits et puis christophe sur
lefigaro.fr qui nous pose sagan azéri la
question fondamentale même si je vous
sens un peu dubitatif pourquoi n'at-on
ce problème qu'avec l'islam l'islam
peut-il s'inscrire dans la république
vous avez déjà s'est rendu à ce point
vous vous semblez en douter parce que
vous considérez que cette religion par
nature parce qu'elle est globalisante
n'est pas une religion c'est aussi une
logique politique c'est un système
juridique est donc à ce sens une app en
ce sens il n'a pas le même statut que
d'autres cultes qui eux nous n'ont pas
la même prétention la même ambition
quant au fait de régir les affaires
humaines donc allé là la difficulté
aujourd'hui avec cette religion là mais
juste pour revenir tout à l'heure sur un
débat sur la langue arabe et sur
l'identité française
j'avoue ne pas comprendre pour le coup
ce débat là parce que dire que
qu'enseignant ou arabe serait une porte
d'entrée vers l'islamisme c'est un peu
sous entendre comme c'est comme ci
serait comme dire des allemands seraient
une porte d'entrée vers le nazisme
l'italien vers le fascisme
il me semble que une langue est neutre
en elle-même est que l offre accès la
littérature de gare aujourd'hui n'a pas
besoin de parler arabe pour pour lire le
coran les essayer de s'imprégner d'une
idéologie totalitaire je ne suis pas
certain que tous les djihadistes qui
aujourd'hui vont combattre en séries
soit complètement bilingue français et
arabe
soit j'en doute très forte fortement le
treuil notre ne trouvons enfin un point
de divergence entre lorient aujourd'hui
il ya aujourd'hui c'est que oui pour
vous encore une fois si les cils et si
les parents souhaitent que l'enfant
pourquoi je distinguerai l'aspect
culturel linguistique de l'aspect
religieux la langue arabe n'est pas
prédéterminer pas prédestiné à faire
entrer les gens dans la religion
musulmane j'ose espérer que la
littérature arabe regorge d'autres
oeuvres que le coran et je pense que
c'est le cas
non je ne pense pas qu'il faille mais
les cette question là est par exemple un
test de jack lang le président de voix
et tout comme je ne pense pas qu'il soit
opportun de lier la question de la lutte
contre l'islam radical à une question
d'assimilation identité française parce
que c'est nier aussi le combat universel
de la lutte contre et idéologie on
oublie qu'il n'y a pas que la france
considère n'y a pas qu'en france qu'on
se débattent contre cette idéologie là
on sort on se bat aussi contre est dans
le monde arabe le monde arabe produits
ca post a produit ces dissidents l'iran
produit ces dissidents contre l'origine
de menaces produit ces dissidents si on
lève le voile donc à réduire si vous
voulez la question d'islam radical à une
opposition locale versus étrangers non
seulement on prend le risque
d'essentialiser les cultures étrangères
qui ont peut-être vocation à évoluer et
à prendre leurs distances à l'égard de
la religion musulmane et ont fait
l'impasse aussi sur et bien tous les
intellectuels étrangers qui regardent
l'occident et qui et c'est précisément
d'acculturation leur pays aux normes
occidentales qui je crois ont une
dimension universelle donc ce n'est pas
une question d'identité française contre
une identité cher c'est une question
civilisationnel c'est est ce que on
considère que les normes occidentales et
normes libérales finalement primes sont
en matière de qualité sur les normes
issues de la civilisation islamique et
ses premiers jo bernard on refera un
débat pour savoir si la civilisation
occidentale est forcément libéral sa
baisse à 2 ans mènerait trop loin merci
beaucoup à tous les deux je laisse le
dernier mot à nos internautes c'est la
question du jour sur lefigaro.fr
séparatisme islamistes croyez vous que
les mesures présentées par emmanuel
macron sont efficaces pour l'instant
c'est un certain doute voir un doute
certain qui prévaut puisque 71% de nos
internautes répondent négativement merci
beaucoup monsieur pour ce débat qui
était fait qu'on plaisir et très bon
week-end à vous chers internautes on se
retrouve avec joie lundi pour un nouveau
point de vue
[Musique]